ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung
heute geht es im Seminar technikethik um
das Thema künstliche Intelligenz und
menschmaschininteraktion bevor wir aber
auf dieses Thema näher eingehen gibt's
noch mal einen Rückblick auf die letzte
Sitzung in der hatten wir es mit Ethik
der Gentechnik zu tun wir hatten uns
gefragt welche Formen von Gentechnik
werden unterschieden und welche
ethischen Probleme gehen mit ihn einher
wir hatten gesehen es gibt verschiedene
Arten von Gentechnik die bet treffen
entweder Pflanzen oder Tiere oder sogar
auch Menschen und je nachdem welche
Lebewesen sie betreffen umso
problematischer werden sie auch aus
ethischer Hinsicht und ich möchte jetzt
noch ein Beispiel geben für eine Form
von Gentechnik die nicht Menschen
sondern Tiere betrifft das hier ist das
Gen scharf Dolly das ein geklontes Tier
dar stellt in England hier ist es
ausgestopft die Quelle ist Wikipedia und
und hier sieht man über den Tod dieses
Tieres dass es infolge einer schweren
Lungenkrankheit verstarb
und zwar nicht ganz das volle Alter
erhalten hatte das normalerweise Schafe
erhalten
und jetzt kann man sich fragen ob es mit
diesem frühen Tod etwas zu tun hat was
auf
die Klontechnik die gchnik
zurückzuführen ist das betrifft jetzt
auch die Technik Folgenabschätzung also
wenn wir nicht ganz sicher sind ob bei
anderen Lebewesen die
Gentechnik sich gut auswirkt dann müssen
wir natürlich umso vorsichtiger sein
wenn wir sie auf Menschen anwenden das
gilt es hier zu bedenken ja gentechnisch
ist ein sehr komplexes Thema was in der
Ethik ganz prominent ähm behandelt wird
ähm wir sehen dass das Thema
Verantwortung ins Zentrum rückt weil wir
eben tief in die menschliche Natur
dadurch eingreifen und wie alle
Technologien hat auch Gentechnologie
zwei Seiten sie kann der Menschheit
Nutzen bringen tut sie auch schon wenn
etwa die Menschheit von Erbkrankheiten
geheilt wird oder teilweise geheilt wird
sie kann aber auch zur Manipulation und
Kontrolle der Menschen eingesetzt werden
Stichwort Designer Babys und so weiter
und so fort
und das betrifft auch auch die Würde des
Menschen geht auf Manuel kan zurück die
bedeutet die Autonomie die würde ist eng
mit der Selbstbestimmung des Menschen
verbunden und wenn wir den Menschen
genetisch manipulieren dann so die
Kritik aus ethischer Perspektive
verletzen wir auch seine Autonomie und
damit seine würde wie sie im Grundgesetz
auch wirgt ist Artikel 1 die Würde des
Menschen ist un tastbar und Artikel 2
ist natürlich auch wichtig wie überhaupt
alle Grundrechte die die Entfaltung der
Persönlichkeit betreffen wir sehen also
es geht auf Emmanuel K zurück wo wir
auch schon diese würde garantiert sehen
und hier gibt's eine Spannung zur
aktuellen gchnik es rückt das Problem
der
verantwortungsvollen Technik Nutzung ins
Zentrum wie genau jetzt Gentechnik
eingesetzt werden kann und soll das sind
zwei ganz verschiedene Fragen natürlich
kann man die Gentechnik für alles
mögliche einsetzen man kann Menschen
klonen oder das zumindest versuchen man
kann Mischwesen erzeugen aus Mensch und
Tier aber ob man das auch wirklich soll
ob das gut ist das ist eine ganz andere
Frage darf die Wissenschaft die
Naturwissenschaft alles tun was sie
durch technischen Fortschritt auch tun
kann oder sollten ihr Grenzen gesetzt
werden ethische Fragen lassen sich oft
nicht eeut beantworten nach einem
mathematischen naturwissenschaftlichen
Ideal sondern müssen h immer pro und
kontra Argumente
abwägen diskutieren mit Expertin und
Experten verschiedener Disziplinen
Philosophie Theologie
Naturwissenschaft Soziologie alle
möglichen Disziplinen können hier
beteiligt sein und nur so kann man dann
zu einem Konsens kommen und es gibt hier
dafür den deutschen Ethikrat der sich
eben auch mit diesem Thema befasst hat
also der getikart sieht man hier
beschäftigt sich mit den großen Fragen
des Lebens natürlich auch mit der
Gentechnik ja Gendiagnostik
Präimplantationsdiagnostik Big Data das
sind alles Dinge die sich der etikrat
zum Gegenstand gemacht hat das ist also
ethische Urteilsfindung die muss immer
viele Perspektiven mit einbeziehen und
sie hat nicht dieses mathematische
gewissheitsideals sprechen hier immer
spielen immer Gründe eine Rolle
Argumente für oder gegen man muss es
abwen en muss an ausgewogenen ethischen
Urteil kommen und diese Urteile sind
immer natürlich auch teilweise auch
problematisch das muss man immer
berücksichtigen dennoch kommt es ganz
wesentlich drauf an dass man der Ethik
argumentiert verschiedene Perspektiven
mit einbezieht möglichst umsichtig
zuinem Urteil kommt einem gerechten
Urteil ja hier stellt sich also vor
allem das Problem der Technik Folgen
Abschätzung wir können oft nur schwer
vorhersehen wie sich diese Techniken
Technologien aus wirken wir haben das
ein Beispiel vom klonscharf Dolly
gesehen wir müssen also sein Technik
Gebrauch reflektieren das ist immer der
Gebrauch der Technik der Einsatz der
Technik und nicht die Technik als solche
als solche ist die Technik Technologie
erstmal überhaupt nicht problematisch
sonst kommt immer darauf an was man mit
ihr macht welche Ziele man mit ihr
verfolgt ob man verantwortungsvoll mit
dir umgeht ob man weiter denkt oder ob
man zu kurz denkt den das ist dieses
grundsätzliche Problem wo sollten jetzt
die ethischen Grenzen der Gentechnik
liegen das ist die Frage die wir uns
gestellt haben und da hat natürlich der
Deutsche Ethikrat sehr viel dazu gesagt
ich möchte jetzt aber auf die heutige
Sitzung eingehen und da geht es um KI
künstliche Intelligenz und
Menschmaschine interteraktion dieses
Thema ist mindestens so aktuell wie das
Thema Gentechnik was schon etwas länger
in der ethischen Debatte prominent ist
inwiefern ist jetzt künstlichen
Intelligenz wirklich intelligent kann
man sich fragen und wie kann man sie
auch für medizinische Zwecke
verantwortungsvoll einsetzten die zwei
Fragen wollen wir uns heute überlegen
und da möchte ich so ein bisschen auch
ein Einblick geben in die konkreten
Anwendung wenn man jetzt sich z.B die
neuen
bildgeneration Modelle anschaut dar E2
wie es so schön heißt hier habe ich den
Auftrag gegeben Male ein Bild von einem
antiken Philosophen der Computer spielt
sowas wird ausgespuckt das sieht schon
sehr Menschen gemacht aus und hier noch
etwas kniffliger erzeuge ein Bild von
einer antiken Vase auf der eine Person
Computer spielt und da kommt dann sowas
raus und das sieht tatsächlich zum
Verwechseln ähnlich man muss natürlich
dazu sagen das ist eine reine Simulation
eine Illusion eine Fiktion in der Antike
gab es natürlich noch keine Computer
aber sowas ist jetzt alles möglich man
sieht es auch im Bereich der Brettspiele
Alpha go z.B ein sehr komplexes
Brettspiel was im asiatischen Raum vor
allem gespielt wird
und Alpha Go ist die künstliche
Intelligenz die soweit gedienen ist dass
sie den weltbesten gopieler besiegt hat
wir sehen das gleich wir sehen das schon
von Schachprogrammen damals gab es sowas
auch deep blue hieß das in 90ern das war
jetzt aber hier im Jahr 2016 und hier
sieht man rechts den l doll den
südkoreanischen Weltmeister im go und
links dieser Mann hier vertritt Google
deep mind diese Alpha go künstliche
Intelligenz jetzt bringe ich mal so ein
paar Szenen zum Ansehen dieser dieses
Spieles es war ein wirklich
sensationelles Spiel man findet auch die
Dokumentation auf Youtube Google deep
mind wurde schon 33 Millionen Fach
angeklickt und wir schauen uns einfach
mal an hier geht es los hier sieht man
von oben die Sicht und hier ist jetzt
der südkoreanische Kommentator im
Fernsehen weil dort eben go sehr wichtig
ist ein wirklicher wichtiger Sport und
hier sieht man er kann kaum glauben wie
gut Alp go die KI sich schlägt er sagt
it so scary also es ist wirklich
geradezu ja
unheimlich und hier schlägt er sich an
den Kopf langte sich an den Kopf und
sagt sogar ein völlig undenkbarer Zug
also man hat nie der KI zugetraut so
gute Züge zu machen das hat alle völlig
erstaunt und hier sieht man auch dann
den Blick dieses gopielers wie er
wirklich verzweifelt ist und selbst sagt
Alpha go diese kai ist kreativ er
spricht ja also menschliche
Eigenschaften zu und so geht's gerade
weiter diese
Association für go hat dieser KI sogar
einen Rang zugeteilt also eine Ehre
zukommen lassen kann man sich natürlich
fragen kann KI wirklich ausgezeichnet
werden ist sie wirklich ein Subjekt das
denkt na ja man muss natürlich
unterscheiden spielen ist nicht dasselbe
wie denken das muss man schön
auseinanderhten und hier ist ein
Statement von diesem
besietten Weltmeister der gegen die KI
verlor er sagt er dachte Alpha go sei
auf
wahrscheinlichkeitskalkulation basiert
aber er sagt nun dass es wirklich
kreativ ist
muss man natürlich hier ein bisschen
einschränkend sagen das Leben ist kein
Brettspiel also es mag sein dass KI bei
Spielen wie Schach und go sehr gut ist
tatsächlich originell ist bislang
unentdeckte Züge vermarkt zu spielen
aber das heißt nicht dass sie wirklich
menschliche Eigenschaften hat deswegen
würde ich sagen vorsicht mit solchen
Zuschreibungen wie Kreativität anderes
Phänomen der künst Intelligenz ist noch
der Chatbot
Chat GPT ich habe mal eingegeben sag mir
was ich tun soll wenn mir langweilig ist
und hier spuckt jetzt dieser chatb mir
Chatbot mir jetzt einige mögliche
Antworten aus die wirklich gut sind also
neues Hobby anfangen und so weiter und
so fort hier ist die ganze Liste die
generiert wurde und das ist wirklich
beeindruckend weil da sehr viele
sinnvolle Dinge drin stehen hat jetzt
der Chatbot wirklich Ideen Gedanken
gehabt oder ist es nur eine Reproduktion
W auch eine sehr komplexe das muss man
sich natürlich fragen und man muss sich
genauso fragen wie es aussieht wenn man
künstlich Intelligenz in der Medizin
anwendet Krankheiten etwa lassen sich
anhand von bestimmten Mustern erkennen
genauso wie sich auch Spielsituation im
go oder Schach von KI anhand von Mustern
sehr gut erkennen lassen also
Mustererkennung ist ein Teil von KI und
insofern lässt sich KI auch gut in der
Medizin anwenden jetzt muss man aber
weiter fragen ob KI auch selbst
Diagnosen stellen kann das ist natürlich
was anderes als ein Muster zu erkennen
Diagnosen sind Empfehlungen aber
natürlich auch Erkenntnisse und ein
weiterer Schritt wäre kann künstlich
Intelligenz selbstptienten behandeln
angenommen die KI entdeckt ein
Krankheitsmuster und wende darauf ein
gesundungsmuster ein therapiemuster
an kann sich jeder mal überlegen ob man
sich gerne von einer KI behandeln oder
auch heilen kurieren operieren im
extremsten Fall lassen würde äh man muss
natürlich dann immer fragen wer trägt
die Verantwortung dafür wenn die KI ein
Behandlungsfehler begeht soll man die KI
bestrafen soll man sie abschalten oder
soll man die Personen bestrafen die sie
programmiert haben man sieht es ist gar
nicht so einfach soll man die Personen
Belangen die zur Datenbasis beigetragen
haben es wird unendlich Komplex wenn man
diese Frage wirk ernst nimmt ja ich
bedanke mich vielmals für die
Aufmerksamkeit und freue mich auf die
nächste gemeinsame
Sitzung